[Music]  Queen P gets cheeky in sexy new  Instagram pics the 36 year old singer  took to social media to show off a  killer new outfit  check out her stylish Celine color-block  top paired with trendy red sunglasses a  baby blue to your reptile print bag and  ankle strap heels but it's Beyonce's  super short : teri cut offs that are the  real showstopper Beyonce flaunted her  famous booty in this shot  giving followers a good look at all the  embellishments on her rear and while  those 108 dollars short Schwartz seemed  a little snug the brand's website  insists that you can comfortably sit in  them ween B is currently on the European  leg of her on the run to tour with hubby  jay-z and of course she's playing every  step of the way  you